und über die situation im aartal kann
ich nun sprechen mit susanne gelhard die
uns aus dernau zugeschaltet ist guten
tag frau gerhard winter probiert wie ist
aktuell die lage vor ort rund zwei
wochen nach der katastrophe
ja wir sind am tag 16 nach dem
hochwasser und es wurde schon einiges
aufgeräumt weggeräumt an schutt und müll
aber die aufräumarbeiten stehen nach wie
vor im mittelpunkt auch hier in dernau
und hier fehlt es immer noch am
nötigsten
als wir heute morgen hier angekommen
sind was stockdunkel das heißt die
menschen hier haben immer noch kein
strom
sie haben immer noch kein fließend
wasser und das mittelalter hier ist
besonders stark betroffen denn hier sind
die hänge besonders steil und besonders
eng hier hat das wasser zehn bis elf
meter hoch gestanden und entsprechend
stark sind auch die schäden wir haben
hier gleich neben uns die aartalbahn die
normalerweise die orte hier verbindet
auf einer länge von 30 kilometern
sie wurde komplett aus den schienen
gehoben ist bis auf weiteres
wahrscheinlich für die nächsten monate
oder auch jahre nicht befahrbar
die infrastruktur wieder herzustellen
das ist jetzt das allerwichtigste auch
dass die leute hier auch die wirtschaft
wieder auf die beine kommt ja stichwort
wirtschaft dernau ist ja einer der
wichtigsten weinorte im aartal kann man
schon absehen ob es eine zukunft für den
weinbau dort geben wird
die wird es natürlich geben und die
winzer hier sind sehr zuversichtlich
aber sie wissen genau sie brauchen lange
zeit dernau ist bekannt für sein wein
das stimmt für den spätburgunder hier
über dem ort man kann das sehr schön
sehen verläuft der rotwein wanderweg und
die winzer hier sind stolz auf ihren
rotwein aber im moment ist das sehr
schwierig in etwa sechs wochen soll die
weinlese beginnt sechs bis acht wochen
aber die winzer sind damit beschäftigt
ihre häuser und vor allen dingen ihre
weinkeller zu reinigen von schlamm zu
befreien
denn wein ist ja ein lebensmittel und
wein muss auch hygienisch und sauber
produziert werden und bis hin hierzu der
gastronomie zu den hotels und
restaurants stockt der betrieb der
tourismus es steht alles still früher
war bernau mit wellness und wein mit
urlaub im spätburgunder paradies und
gerade hatten sich hier die hotel würde
die restaurantbesitzer nach einer
schweren corona zeit darauf vorbereitet
dass es wieder losgeht sie hatten
hoffnung geschöpft und dann kam dieses
unglaubliche hochwasser also das sieht
im moment nicht gut aus der
tourismusverband sagt zwölf monate wird
es hier in sachen tourismus wohl
überhaupt nicht vorwärts gehen und dann
so schöpft man hoffnung vielleicht
wieder bergauf ja manch einer bemüht
sich jetzt immer schon nach vorne zu
schauen wir haben vorhin den bericht
über einen schreiner ja gehört und ich
habe gesehen hier und da werden sogar
schon straßen neu geteert heißt das es
gibt schon pläne für den wiederaufbau
die straße die sie wahrscheinlich
gesehen haben ist eine straße in
mayschoß dass es etwas flussaufwärts die
wurde von privatleuten von einem
bauunternehmer gebaut damit das dorf
überhaupt besser zugänglich ist das ist
aber auch ein provisorium die
infrastruktur hat so stark gelitten dass
jetzt zunächst mal eine schadensaufnahme
erst nötig ist und dann eine vorsichtige
schätzung mehrere milliarden schäden da
muss man erst mal einen plan
wie man hier am aartal entlang aufbaut
wesentlich betroffen sind auch die
menschen es wurde kurz angesprochen die
jetzt ihre häuser begutachten lassen
müssen da werden experten in die häuser
geschickt teilweise bekommen die
menschen die botschaft die häuser sollen
abgerissen werden das ist natürlich
verheerend für viele hier die über
generationen in diesem tal wohnen
das heißt bevor eine infrastruktur
überhaupt wieder aufgebaut werden kann
muss es erstmal einen plan geben soll
einen nationalen wiederaufbau plan geben
hat die rheinland pfälzische
ministerpräsident in malu dreyer gestern
angekündigt zusammen mit bund und land
und das möglichst bald
das war susanne gelhard aus dernau im
aartal vielen dank für diese
schilderungen